oui
[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur le plateau
de la grande interview pour parler
aujourd'hui d'un sujet un peu tabou un
non seulement en france mais
pratiquement dans le monde entier mais
un sujet d'actualité puisque c'est
l'industrie nucléaire dont il est
question vient de se dérouler en effet à
paris le forum mondial de l'industrie
nucléaire ça se passait à villepinte les
organisateurs n'ont pas fait beaucoup de
publicité et pourtant il y avait là à
paris pendant presque une semaine la
majorité des experts des acteurs et des
industriels de cette industrie mondiale
il y avait à la fois les industriels qui
présentaient leurs activités et leurs
projets mais il y avait aussi la réunion
des ministres concernés bref une sorte
de g-20 du nucléaire alors avec tout sur
ce plateau pour essayer d'y voir clair
et pour nous nous éclairer partenaire de
ce forum gilles rémy bonjour bonjour le
grand public ne vous connais pas bien
mais merci d'accepter de nous apporter
un peu de lumière sur cette question
gilles rémy vous êtes un industriel est
présidente du groupe si fall sa groupe
de commerce international très présent
en russie très présente dans les pays
d'asie et notamment d'asie centrale avec
des bureaux de représentation vous
passez sans doute beaucoup plus de temps
là bas que chez nous un pari sauf que en
regardant les archives je me suis aperçu
que vous aviez conseillé dans l'ombre
pratiquement tous les gouvernements
français depuis françois mitterrand
puisque vous avez été appelés notamment
par jacques chirac c'est le premier sans
doute qu'ils qui vous a appelé nicolas
sarkozy vous étiez françois hollande
vous avez fait tous les tous les tous
les premier ministre françois fillon
bien sûr alain juppé c'est quoi votre
métier
mon métier c'est de c'est d'organiser
des coopérations autant que possible
avec principalement avec une zone qui
est une partie de l'ex urss qui est la
russie l'asie centrale et le caucase
avec l'azerbaïdjan notamment et c'est de
cette expertise qu'il s'agit de m
j'espère tease de plusieurs dizaines
d'années sur le terrain qu'il s'agit de
mettre au service de projets de projets
autant que possible
intéressant pour toutes les parties et
pour tous les pays pour la france comme
pour la russie ou pour les pays d'asie
centrale alors expliquez nous ce ce qui
s'est passé non non dans ce forum que
que doute on n'a pas beaucoup vu les
détails ou la qualité même si ça n'était
pas c'est pas un forum clandestins
s'étaient très public car elle le forum
nucléaire à paris c'est la deuxième ou
troisième fois que ça laisse hélas la
troisième édition effectivement alors
qu'ils accusaient qui aurait dû lieu dû
se tenir l'année dernière et qu'il
faudra du raison du cobp il n'a pas pu
avoir lieu et ce qui fait que depuis
deux depuis deux ans les acteurs du
nucléaire ne se retrouvent plus tous
ensemble physiquement et donc c'était un
moment important alors les acteurs d'une
clairière il ya les gouvernements et les
industriels et financiers là les lobbys
aussi favorablement
c'est une c'est une marmite incroyable
aujourd'hui oui alors c'est un à la fois
c'est un petit monde parce que les
acteurs du nucléaire se retrouvent tous
les ans a notamment à londres pour un
pour un forum forum mondial et donc
raison c'est à 7,1 par rapport à
d'autres industries effectivement il ya
déjà moins d'acteurs il y à sinsin ça
concerne effectivement les industriels
et puis les grands opérateurs qui sont
les russes et français
les américains et les chinois alors
c'est assez paradoxal la situation et ça
explique peut-être le côté un peu non
pas mystérieux mais tabou du du sujet
c'est que tous les experts nous affirmer
chiffres à la clé que nous aurons et
nous avons besoin du nucléaire et que on
a une opinion publique derrière et donc
des politiques qui sont très prudents
très réservé oui alors il ya une très
grande confusion c'est vrai et puis une
très grande un problème de lisibilité
effectivement des politiques publiques
niveau depuis depuis une dizaine
d'années puisque il ya encore 7 8 ans
certains voulaient en terminer avec le
nucléaire en france on est arrivé il ya
une part directe des rationalité
économique quand on a décidé que le
nucléaire ça serait 50 % de notre
électricité ni moi ni plus pourquoi 50
pas 40 tout 55 et c'est donc on voit
bien qu'on est sur un terrain qui
n'était pas celui de la rationalité
économique en tout cas traités par
certains certains politiques et et en
plus on définit une barre un chiffre
absolu sans savoir quelles vont être nos
besoins notamment l'électricité et par
le dieu du rapport rte qui montre bien
que d'ici 2050 eh bien il faudra il
faudra 50 % de production électrique en
plus comment va-t-on faire alors le gia
qui a sonné la
fête signal d'alarmé sur les risques du
réchauffement climatique
a dit bien que les besoins en
électricité sont considérables et
qu'avec la nécessité de couvrir ses
besoins il faudra nécessairement
maintenir une industrie nucléaire oui
mais je pense que ça effectivement c'est
là c'est le principe de réalité
puisqu'on peut on peut rêver à couvrir
toute la planète de d'éoliennes mais
quand ça produit un tiers du temps que
fait-on pour le reste et puis
réellement avec l'électrique je pense
notamment la voiture électrique on a on
déplace finalement là la pollution ne
sera plus dans le coeur des villes mais
elle sera dans la recherche des métaux
rares pour pour les batteries et donc de
toute façon là un processus et puis il
ya aussi la démographie pensons toujours
à l'afrique quand même avec un milliard
d'habitants plus
une afrique où il ya 800 millions de
personnes qui n'ont pas accès à
l'électricité
donc comment va-t-on produire la surface
de l'afrique ne sera pas suffisante pour
mettre des panneaux solaires ou sinon ça
se fera au détriment de l'agriculture
donc il faut réfléchir effectivement à
des solutions qui intègrent le nucléaire
y compris l'afrique avec les contraintes
particulières suppose quelle est la
place aujourd'hui du nucléaire sur la
planète
l'industrie nucléaire pour produire les
alors les sept elle est très inégal il
ya des pays qui ont été les premiers
pays qui sont les états unis avec la
hélas hélas et l'union soviétique et la
russie dans sont les deux premiers pays
ce sont les deux premiers pays la russie
est un géant du nucléaire mais
finalement produit moins dans son
électricité produits - à partir du
nucléaire c'est seulement 20% au nous
nous sommes le gaz pour cent parce que
là le gaz et c est là où c'est et nous
nous sommes soixante dix 70 75 70 73 est
donc celle record mondial et nous avons
effectivement ce plan messmer qui a été
un incroyable défi industriel et qui a
réussi et qui fait qu'aujourd'hui nous
sommes le pays qui produit l'électricité
la plus décarbonés au monde oui alors ça
c'est la carte géographique d'aidé
production nucléaire qu'elle lesquels
elle quels sont les rapports de force
maintenant sur la planète en matière de
technologie ou de capacités de
production alors vous avez pour ses
besoins propres le plus grand
investisseur c'est effectivement la
chine c'est d'ailleurs le paradoxe est
que le p r qui est une conception
française le seul ppr qui fonctionne
aujourd'hui dans le monde il est en
chine ils ont produit plus rapidement
que nous le p r sur lequel on est 13h le
pen on est en retard en un nerd on est
en retard en france et là très
clairement ça a été un échec de notre
politique industrielle d'avoir de
laisser deux opérateurs au même moment
faire d d d d d expérience en tout cas
de se lancer chacun dans leur projet
plutôt que de combiner les compétences
on en paye le prix aujourd'hui précisons
que prc véritablement l'unité de
production la plus nécessaire la plus
importante pour couvrir le maximum de
besoins
pas exactement le p r c'est un c'est une
très grosse capacité sais c'est mille
600 gigawatts c'est à dire c'est la plus
grosse capacité ça ne peut correspondre
qu'à des pays qui ont les
infrastructures des pays très
industrialisés y compris les
infrastructures de transport de
l'électricité le s'éteint c'est un
produit de de qui est qui est cher mais
technologiquement très avancées mais qui
correspond aux besoins de la planète
pouvait pas mettre un ep air dans un
dans un petit pays ou dans un pays qui
n'aura pas ensuite comme le bangladesh
voilà et donc ça ne suffit pas aux
besoins et il faut remarquer que ce sont
les russes qui ont la gamme pourquoi les
russes sont très forts à l'exportation
c'est parce qu'ils ont une gamme très
complète et en fuite des avec dédé
notamment des réacteurs plus de capacité
plus réduite et qui correspondent plus à
à certains marchés donc un donc dans le
classement des ddd des acteurs
technologiquement avancées sur la
planète la chine la russie la russie
parce que c'est elle qui a le plus gros
carnet de commandes à l'export 130
milliards c'est le numéro un à l'export
export
c'est à dire que c'est eux qui
travaillent plus avec les chinois et
alors ils travaillent avec les chinois
ils travaillent avec vous savez
aujourd'hui les centrales nucléaires qui
sont qui sont signés ou en cours de
signature ça va de la de la hongrie avec
pax 2 c'est le sait le bangladesh c'est
l'egypte
c'est la ddt ça a été l'iran à une
époque et donc c'est un marché très très
très très très large et là est le carnet
de commandes est important et je crois
que les élèves parce que la la la gamme
que beaucoup plus adaptés ou adaptables
aux besoins des pays considérés
troisième en france alors troisième
c'est la france le troisième c'est la
france alors les etats-unis sont une
puissance en termes industriels
nucléaires n'oublions pas que même
d'autres combustibles dans nos centrales
nucléaires il est fourni majoritairement
ou à peu près équivalent équivalente
avec framatome parler par westinghouse a
donc c'est un autre technologie au
départ on l'a on l'a prise aux
américains westinghouse et les
américains sont toujours très actifs
aujourd'hui ils veulent vendre leur
combustible nucléaire à des centrales de
conception soviétique russe à l'ukraine
ce qui peut poser d'ailleurs des
problèmes de compatibilité
mais ils sont très très offensif c'était
sur le terrain les uns et les autres
sont beaucoup plus pragmatique que dans
les discours politiques oui absolument
c'est ce qu'il vous détendra de
m'expliquer donc la coopération et
c'était l'objet de ma question elles
existent au niveau des opérations elles
existent après c'est une opinion moi je
pense que elles existent sur un seul
compte tenu des défis de la planète
compte tenu des défis de la filière
nucléaire moi je pense que on devrait
beaucoup plus coopérer on aurait
beaucoup plus coopérer parce que
le nucléaire va pas évoluer aussi on va
passer à d'autres il ya déjà des
coopérations qui seconde sur le
nucléaire du futur
la fusion nucléaire notamment mais
également aujourd'hui moi je pense que
que notre industrie nucléaire a un
intérêt
principalement à coopérer avec la russie
évidemment est ce que la france a
reconstruit son potentiel ou à préserver
son potentiel de s'agit d'une question
c'est une vraie question parce que qui
s'est posée d'ailleurs enfoncés 20 ans
en construction et et donc vous avez
toute une génération
qui est parti à la retraite de gens
extrêmement qualifiés et qu'ils ont qui
sont d'ailleurs qui manquent même sur le
marché mondial il ya des agences de
recrutement qui cherchait compris pour
du personnel qualifié pour le par
exemple recettes home pour d'autres
d'autres constructeurs c'est presque un
marché mondial aujourd'hui un métier en
voilà et mais en revanche avec l'image
très très mauvaises qui a été accolé au
nucléaire au cours des six dernières
années il ya un problème de recrutement
dans les écoles d'ingénieurs aussi
puisque ses plus prestigieux d'aller
d'aller bosser pour google que pour que
pour une l'activité nucléaire voilà donc
il va il peut y avoir un vrai problème
de nos compétences ça sera vrai défilé
alors on va revenir là sur l'image que
peut avoir le nucléaire et
l'attractivité
qui est compliqué à
faire valoir pour pour assurer son
développement on se retrouve dans un
quart de seconde on va faire une petite
pause
[Musique]
bien retour sur le plateau de la grande
interview avec gilles rémy qui est le
président du groupe siph alain groupe
qui est très présent au niveau du
commerce international et notamment dans
les relations entre l'europe la russie
et les pays d'asie centrale pour parler
de ce nucléaire dont on a beaucoup parlé
cette semaine dans le cadre du forum de
de villepinte consacrée à l'avenir de
l'industrie nucléaire qui réunissait là
tous les ministres les experts et les
ailes et les industriels
quand vous nous dites que les acteurs
auraient intérêt à coopérer sur le plan
mondial vous vous pensez à quoi
exactement quelle élection les quais sur
les filières de père parce que c'est
quand même très concurrencé
concurrencer ses concurrents c'est un
c'est un marché qui est concurrentiel
mais mais quand on pense que le notre
industrie nucléaire notre notre capacité
a été aujourd'hui on en parle
différemment aujourd'hui puisque le
présent la république a dit
effectivement on va reconstruire on
était copains à qui il ya encore il ya
encore quelques mois en parlant des
petites scènes rapides en parlant d'aidé
dans des godillots ppr d'une barbe est
sorti les nombreux on peut estimer que
c'est à feu vert pour 6 à 8 vpr en
france donc ça va être une renaissance
de l'industrie nucléaire en termes de
affaire de construction
alors que dans le même temps on avait
donné l'armé pour ça mais on est armé je
pense qu'on a effectivement une expert
une expérience il est très important
aussi de pouvoir planifier puisque si
nous avons été la maîtrise des coûts'
d'un noeud
prl dépend effectivement qui dut du fait
qu'ils aient puis une une
une expérience sur des séries c'est pour
ça que notre programme nucléaire on a pu
construire cinquante sept réacteurs en
une vingtaine d'années c'est parce qu'il
y avait effectivement il y avait des
retours d'expérience et c'est donc c'est
un défi mais un défi réalisable compte
tenu de notre de de la la la la la
puissance est de 2,2 de deux expertises
ddf1
là la vraie question en termes
internationale c'est que on voit bien
les leviers les lobbys sont mondiaux et
internationaux et elle intéresse et pas
c'est que par rapport à la demande qui
peut s'exprimer c'est tout simplement
que l'on puisse ton puisse travailler
lors ce qui est déjà le cas il ya des
coopérations qui jetons y compris dans
la construction des centrales d'autres
pays différents ce qui est ce qui est
intéressant aussi à souligner c'est que
1,1 des freins à priori du nucléaire
c'est l'émergence de nouvelles sources
d'énergie a failli à légaliser rhji
fossiles notamment le gaz
mais il ya aussi les énergies
alternatives et energy nass naturel
comment on en est on est ce que est ce
que ça suffira ou est-ce qu'au contraire
il faudra faire un choix entre
l'hydrogène le gaz le nucléaire ou est
ce que tout ça est complémentaire je
pense que c'est complémentaire après
c'est toute la question de ce qu'on met
dans ce mixte énergétique
ce qui apparaît de plus en plus
évidemment aujourd'hui c'est qu'on ne
peut pas se passer du nucléaire qui dans
certains pays comme la france notamment
de rajouts et un rôle important je
voudrais quand même heureux dire que le
bon joue aux apprentis sorciers y
compris au niveau européen quand un pays
comme l'allemagne décide du jour au
lendemain d'arrêter le nucléaire groove
relais chantal des centrales à charbon
et l'allemagne est le plus gros
pollueurs européens aujourd'hui donc ça
pose un problème on vit sur des
promesses c'est que l'allemagne passe
arrivera en 2035 à 80 % d'énergies
renouvelables
personne ne l'a démontré les meilleurs
mais l'allemagne dans son gouvernement
qui est en train de s'installer s'engage
à abandonner le charbon dans les trente
ans oui c'est ça mais ce sont des
engagements d'auxerre de tenir les
engagements en attendant chaque matin
sur les rives de la seine on est
peut-être plus pollué par le charbon
allemand que par
que par nos propres sources de par notre
propre consommation d'électricité
beaucoup d'experts ne jure que par
l'hydrogène disant vous ne parlez pas
assez d'hydrogène méfiez-vous c'est
quand même une énergie formidable alors
les déjà l'hydrogène c'est pas une
source primaire d'énergie libère c'est à
dire c'est à dire qu'on est là on la
trouve pas comme ça il faut il faut la
fabriquer et donc c'est un vecteur puis
il exactement et donc à partir de quoi
on produit de yolaine saut à partir du
gaz comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui 95%
aujourd'hui de l'hydrogène mondial et
est produit à partir de gaz et là les
russes les russes sont alors les
réponses les russes alors pour eux cette
stratégie pour les russes l'hydrogène
effectivement l'hydrogène parce qu'ils
ont de vrais de vrais atouts et on peut
produire à partir du laz elle à l'avenir
ce conte de ce qu'on souhaite c'est
produire à partir d électrolyse
d'ailleurs ce qu'on veut faire du verre
ou du
tout cas du bas carbonée mais pour ça
pour l'électro il faut l'électricité est
faux de l'eau et des douilles aller très
vite et on retombe sur le effectivement
il faut une source d'énergie le
l'hydrogène état est un vecteur et les
narines des énergies primaires c'est
évidemment le nucléaire c'est le
nucléaire comme ça comme ça sera le gaz
aussi est-ce qu'on n'arrivera pas à
produire de l'hydrogène par rapport aux
besoins qui s'expriment
sans sans gaz alors si finalement il ya
deux faits qui sont sortis sur lesquels
n'y a pas débat c'est un c'est l'énergie
une des énergies les plus propres le
nucléaire et 2 s'est sali par laquelle
il faudra passer si l'on veut satisfaire
tous les besoins oui comment se fait il
et comment se fait-il que y ait de tels
frein une telle une telle réticence des
opinions publiques et qu'est ce qu'on
peut faire pour justement convaincre les
opinions publiques qui a key qui a
nécessité à aller dans ce dans ce
secteur là les opinions publiques elles
ont gardé en mémoire l'accident de
tchernobyl les opinions publiques elles
ont gardé en mémoire des accidents qui a
eu au pour gauchers
est-ce qu'on a tiré les leçons de tout
ça est ce qu on a tiré les leçons de ces
accidents est-ce que la russie par
exemple a tiré les leçons de tchernobyl
aujourd'hui oui tous les pays l'est si
le p r aussi chers c'est parce qu'on a
des tas on à renforcer les sécurités les
centrales russes aussi avec l'aide
d'ailleurs dans les années 90 où la
russie était au plus bas avec l'aide de
deux ddf parce que l'intérêt d'edf là
vous parlez de coopération c'était que
le kkl que les russes ne renonce pas au
nucléaire parce que on ne voulait pas
rester tout seul et donc on a beaucoup
aidé et aujourd'hui effectivement le
lait les termes de normes de sécurité
mais aussi de l'augmentation des coûts
puisque tous et ça c'est tout ces
équipements supplémentaires coûtent
beaucoup d'argent
en ce qui concerne que faut-il faire
pour quoi les aimait déjà il faudrait
commencer par parle par l'école quand on
pense aux 50% je crois où j'ai passé la
population ou des élèves se pense que le
nucléaire produit du co2 donc que donc
on a un vrai problème effectivement
installé un sentiment de sécurité de
sécurité et puis et puis aujourd'hui
l'opinion été faite par par des ong par
des ddd lobby internationaux très
puissant qui promeuvent d'ailleurs le le
les énergies alternatives
enfin des éoliennes ou les solaires qui
sont aujourd'hui le qui polluent qui
polluée visuellement mais qui polluent
par les matériaux qui ont un roman faut
toujours le rappeler qui est
intermittent et qui ne peuvent pas
répondre aux besoins et qui coûte cher
puisque jean votre facture edf ou payer
le fait que edf doit vendre un prix très
bas ce qui est ce qui là encore est
assez paradoxal parce que les français
dont l'énergie est à 70% nucléaire n'en
profite pas alors il en possède déjà le
paye à un prix d'électricité qui est
équivalent à ceux qui consomment de
l'électricité du gaz ou du charbon oui
enfin heure où denis drolet l'instant
pour l'instant nos factures
d'électricité sont quand même une baisse
plus modeste que les fronts allemagne où
on coache kosova glee c'est compliqué là
dans le raisonnement que vous tenez et
notamment je me souviens de d'exposer de
gens de vous connaissez bien booster les
gens de la cogema vous devez travailler
à la jetée marin j'aimerais bien sûr à
qui nous et il me disait la sécurité
elle viendra du grand nombre de
centrales que nous fabriquons si nous
fabriquons beaucoup de centrales du même
type on peut assurer la sécurité
beaucoup plus facilement et
et ray est préservée tout ça mais mais
mais mais si vous fabriquez beaucoup
beaucoup de centrales vous prenez aussi
beaucoup plus de risques peut-être oui
alors dans la fabrique africaine central
de toute façon un grand réacteurs les
grands réacteurs qu'on connaît du type
ppr ou des de dvr russe à l'export ça
reste quand même des installations des
infrastructures massive appuyer mon palm
bond de 2,2 pour pma 20 milliards pour
l'un des deux réacteurs russes et 10
milliards et donc il ya du génie civil
ça reste quand même du sur mesure même
s'il peut y avoir les retours
d'expérience mais l'avenir du nucléaire
ça passe aussi par les petits réacteurs
est d'ailleurs la république il a donné
son feu vert pour ça et là il faut qu'on
fasse très vite parce qu'on sera pas les
premiers sur le marché et russes sont
présents les russes sont les sont
présents et les rues sont les premiers
c'est toujours cette cette barge
flottante qui aujourd'hui alimente une
ville du grand nord russe et le
nucléaire fait peur aussi à cause des
ddd tentation militaire oui alors c'est
là où les gouvernements sont pas bien
calé en termes de polices belges mais en
fait tu le sais pas et c'est pas une
centrale nucléaire qui qui qui nous
opprime puisque de toute façon on est
sur du combustible faiblement enrichi
pour se doter d'une capacité nucléaire
il faut l'enrichir et donc c'est le
problème des centrifugeuses de cela il y
aura donc il n'y a pas une centrale
nucléaire n'est pas un élément de 2,2 de
risque de diffusion que continue le
nucléaire il fait peur à cause des
déchets alors je pars à cause des
déchets vous n'avez jamais vous vous
êtes dans le milieu vous n'avez pas
régler le problème dès lors le problème
du déchet rappelons quand même que le
déchet ultime c'est une tout quelques
pourcents du du combustible de l'uranium
ont retraité encore partie donc le
déchet ultime il est en masse il et il
est limité celui qu'on peut enterrer
et puis après un programme et puis la
nouvelle génération le nucléaire de
demain il produira plus de déchets si
rémy vous connaissez bien la russie et
pour terminer je voudrais qu'on termine
à dessus
sur votre analyse des rapports entre la
france et la haye la russie est ce que
le nucléaire par exemple peut être un
sujet un objet pour améliorer la
coopération
moi je pense que le nucléaire c'est
c'est déjà un domaine de coopération de
coopération historique puisque la france
a été le premier pays à l'époque brejnev
jusqu'à acheter aux russes des services
d'enrichissement on n'avait pas de
capacité suffisante d'enrichissement
d'uranium pour nos centrales et on le
faisait et sa durée pendant des années
aujourd'hui on le fait avec l'uranium de
retraitement etc il ya beaucoup beaucoup
des changes qui ceux qui se font mais je
pense qu'on n'est pas passé parce que ça
suppose effectivement de la confiance et
une vraie volonté politique au plus haut
niveau à d'une vraie coopération y
compris pour aller ensemble sur des
marchés
qui peut rêver parce qu'ils savent ça
pose des défis en termes de financement
sa porte et je pense que l'on pourrait
tout à fait complété no no no no
savoir-faire nos valeurs valeurs propres
les deux chefs d'état sont des deux pays
sont pas vues depuis la mort le 18 le
sien kiena macron avait démarré
sous les lambris du château de
versailles avec la visite officielle de
polluants petit
président français est allé à saint
pétersbourg pour un forum économique oui
mais pas allé depuis et il a été à
moscou pour la coupe du monde mais il
n'a pas fait jusqu'à présent
effectivement sous la vème république
c'est le premier président qui n'a pas
fait le voyage officiel en russie
qu'est-ce qui va pas on a une situation
on n'est pas seulement leurs biens à
hauteur et une situation que
l'international quand même difficile on
les voyait lahlimi voilà alors je mets
aussi des détentions qu'on n'avait pas
connu
il ya depuis des dizaines d'années donc
un climat difficile alors bon il se
parle il parle mais en fait se parler
c'est pas se rencontrer et puis pour se
rencontrer encore et il faut peut-être
préparés surgelés l'ailé les éléments
d'une coopération future et vous qui
connaissez bien est ce que les
dirigeants russes ont véritablement la
connaissance des codes de fonctionnement
des démocraties européennes
je pense qu'ils nous connaissent mieux
que nous les connaissons ouais et alors
est il simplement c'est que
s'il ne modifie s'il ne il ne s'exprime
pas s'il ne se conduisent pas exactement
comme on souhaiterait qu'il le fasse
c'est parce qu'ils veulent ils le font
pour de bonnes raisons et avant tout
c'est pour correspondre à leurs hôtes en
leur public leurs opinions publiques
absolue à jérémy merci beaucoup merci de
cette de cet éclairage rappelle que vous
êtes président du groupe siph al je
rappelle aussi que vous êtes conseiller
du commerce extérieur de france
c'est vous n'êtes pas aux fonctionnaires
mais n'ont cessé de fonctionner les
fonctions à la de conseil où on est
trois mille en france vous êtes et 3000
en france mais vous
c'est un réseau très dense de sous la
vieille institution sur lequel se
reposent d'ailleurs beaucoup
d'industriels français d'entreprises qui
vont à l'étranger ils veulent capter un
marché où s'est installée chacun son
expertise merci on retrouve des missions
en rediffusion sur la chaîne gratuite en
replay bien sûr et puis sur le site
internet rt france point tv à très
bientôt
[Musique]